I'm writing every devil fruit in one
piece to figure out which is the best
one today we're looking at the yomiomino
me the revive provide fruit a devil
fruit that gives you the ability to
literally come back to life after you
die this fruit is owned by the musician
of the straw hats Brooke in terms of
strength the revived fruit allows its
user to deal devastating damage to other
Soul powers and its Soul energy also
gives you ice powers quite impressive so
it gets 15 points here when it comes to
durability the fruit literally gives you
a second life if you die during battle
however this can only be used once and
if you're revived as a skeleton you can
even survive losing your head 10 points
for special abilities with this fruit
you can literally leave your body and go
through walls combined with all the
other crazy bonus abilities it deserves
a perfect 25 points here however the
revive food does have one major drawback
to unlock any of its special abilities
you literally have to die once first for
that we have to deduct 10 points for a
total of 60 which actually puts it in
second place for now